en moyenne au canada les automobilistes
restent coincés 28 heures par an dans la
circulation et ce qui n'aide pas c'est
que de plus en plus d'usagers de la
route s'établissent en périphérie ce qui
favorise l'étalement urbain dans la
grande région de québec par exemple
lorsqu'on additionne la rive-nord et la
rive-sud
la population ne cesse d'augmenter en
2036 elle dépassera les neuf cent mille
habitants donc de plus en plus de gens
sur la route et pas assez de voix pour
désengorger le réseau
on estime donc qu une des solutions
passe par un troisième lien entre la
rive nord et la rive sud
mais pourquoi un troisième lien
d'abord parce que le premier le pont de
québec montre des signes de fatigue et
que le deuxième le pont pierre laporte
ne suffit plus à la demande
ensuite parce qu'en cas d'accident sur
un des deux liens la circulation devient
ingérable
donc on propose un troisième accès
routier sous forme de pont ou de tunnels
pour relier la vieille capitale à la
ville de lévis sur la rive-sud
actuellement cinq scénarios sont sur la
table 1 à l'ouest de québec pour relier
l'autoroute 40 et les quatre autres à
l'est dont celui d'un tunnel qui
passerait sous le fleuve à la pointe de
l'île d'orléans prix de ces projets
difficile à dire mais le chiffre de 4
milliards revient le plus souvent
et c'est en 2020 qu'un seul tracé sera
retenue selon certains sondages le
projet aurait la faveur de 80% de la
population ici le gouvernement sortant
de philippe couillard vise 2026 pour la
construction et la caq de françois
legault voudrait même devancé les
travaux
alors c'est réglé pas si vite
depuis près de 30 ans la plupart des
études et des exemples démontrent que
plus on améliore les infrastructures
routières plus il y à de nouveaux usages
et c'est ce qu'on appelle le trafic
induit
ainsi à court terme l'ajout d'un
troisième lien permettrait de
désengorger les deux autres mais bien
vite la demande va suivre l'offre
et ce sera le retour de la congestion
générés par les banlieusards en milieu
urbain
alors que faire imposer un péage pour
inciter à réduire le trafic s'est peu
vendable politiquement améliorer le
transport collectif est une solution à
condition qu'ils soient abordables et
surtout plus efficace c'est-à-dire plus
rapide que la voiture ce qui n'est pas
le cas ici dans la grande région de
québec alors la congestion automobile
est elle une fatalité
en tout cas elle est symptomatique de
milieu urbain en croissance et en
attendant la solution
les heures de pointe resteront toujours
des heures de pointe